bien vis bien vite mon amour de petit
chien vie qui c'est qui va voir un
anneau sens ici c'est le petit bimbo à
sa grande soeur est dû mais bon sang
mais elle va nous écouter
oui c'est la chaîne monsieur beauchamp
ne me l'a confié pendant son absence où
il est parti pour quelques jours il ne
pouvait pas mieux tomber
obtient pendant que j'y suis donné moi
quelques bonbons demain nous est fait
vous ne devriez pas lui donner des
bonbons le sucre c'est très mauvais pour
les chiens oh oui les enterrements qui
regarde et il nous regarde si tendrement
devant yann mes très chers amis de
retrouver tous réunis que le cep la
nouvelle j'organise un coucou si disney
concours superbe concours de coiffure
oui de coiffure jacob pour un petit les
chapeaux mais parfaitement géré produits
coiffure de tous alors ces bolides et
françois when
they le chili c'est pas génial
et je vous jure t au moins bon bah oui
oui vous
moi j'ai beaucoup de travail c'est ces
jours ci s'est désolé et puis moi je
dois continuer la lecture de ce livre
passionnant oui témoin outre mad
m'occuper d'eux est adorable petit chien
oui âge il faut que je termine quatre
rapports sur la qualité du gazon dont
jardin monsieur 19 avez vous parlé de
votre concours à casimir et à leonard
non pas encore non ma chère amie j'y
vais de ce pas j'espère qu'ils sont plus
enthousiastes que vous bon vous prenez
toujours le règlement du concours on ne
sait jamais si vous changez d'avis tu
n'es bientôt et alors juste à ce moment
là monsieur
tombe dans l'eau
déplaçant un gros engin et qu'est ce que
je vois de sous un énorme poisson gourou
mais le gourou roues aux coraux pour sûr
gros coucou énorme énorme je me
précipite dessus
ça c'est vous monsieur 19 ans très bien
bonjour quelques bonjour leona à gérer
mais je veux chercher partout j'ai une
grande nouvelle à vous apprendre une
nouvelle et alors les normes poisson
pour alléger
le poids se sont tus nordique nouvelle
nouvelle le petit ou un shu
alors cette nouvelle bon alors là
j'organise un grand concours de coiffure
ce qu'on gagne on gagne une énorme
gâteau au choix
je le vis de terminer ma tournée alors
je n'allais même préparé devant ma glace
ont pour sûr si je pouvais gagner ce
concours je serais très heureux attend
dé moi et mais je viens tout de suite
excusez-moi j'ai beaucoup de travail
installé une estrade et chaises permet à
tout à l'heure un rôle du tass
un concours alors je vais me mettre un
bigoudis là une barre est là et puis et
vit peut-être un ruban qu'en penses-tu
casimir la la mon pauvre léonard mais
qui n'a aucune chance de gagner ce
concours qu'elle n'a pas de cheveux du
nac des poils points ouais des points
des points
mais tu peux toujours parler toi parce
que tu n'as ni cheveux ni points 1 alors
mais menée alors chacun court alti dion
attend il faut trouver une idée ouais
nous allons faire un tour dans l'île je
passe par mon tunnel nous nous
retrouvons dernière le kiosque à cran et
emporte toujours tes grands ciseaux un
ça peut toujours servir d'accord
d'accord d'accord léonard tout de suite
il faut absolument trouver une idée
que penses tu de la coiffure 15 me
je suis sûr qu'on tient de monsieur bons
gènes a beaucoup moins chaud maintenant
ah oui et puis cette pointe de canif
sont magnifiques on dirait une période
de marty comme les aime monsieur du snob
je crois que j'ai une chance de gagner
le concours et le gâteau de mon choix et
toi peut-être moi ça va je vais encore
couper un peu ici aplatir l'art et
couper un peu de rhum attention ne le
raccourci pas trop comme ça c'est bien
ouais j'espère que mademoiselle futé ne
nous a pas vus prendre son gazon
j'espère
que qu'est-ce que je pourrais bien faire
pour qu'elle soit bien lisse à
il n'y a qu'à la mouiller et ensuite la
cua soigneusement pas très bonne idée
attends un peu d'eau tu as raison
voilà pas trop voilà
bonjour julie un bon jour soit tu
portent des foulards maintenant eh bien
oui parce que le temps est fract pas
mais possède supporter des chapeaux oui
moi c'est parce qu'il y avait le soleil
aujourd'hui
tu crois pas que nos explications de
concorde pas prévient julie soit france
2 prépare pour le concours de coiffure
2010 le
secteur
rogarde et pas sous mon chapeau
messieurs j'ai le grand honneur
l'inestimable avantage de vous annoncer
qu'au troisième gong le grand concours
de coiffure sera ouvert alors attention
les participantes apparaît vous
[Musique]
deux
et trois le chien sera difficile et nous
attendons les derniers concurrents
regardez le chêne monsieur prochaine je
ne me suis absenté que quelques-uns sont
tous
mes plantations
et mon gazon a disparu mesdames et
mesdames messieurs ne percevait pas
lassé du concours vous participez vous
imputez oui alors asseyez-vous à et
voici les deux derniers concurrents vous
prend casimir
casimir à pose-toi d'après la réaction
du public
[Applaudissements]
mardi pour toi
c'est mérité c'était une petite idée à
moi le gazon
puisque je suis le gagnant allez vite me
préparais mon énorme gâteau drame j'ai
bien mérité de le manger tout seul un
sourire